par la droite là on ne peut que le
retrouver raymond bêcher il est
incontournable dans son paysage
maire depuis près de 25 ans et son dada
après la relance du commerce
c'est le toilettage de l'ancien café
c'est la partie très ancienne du bourg
ce qui nous amène d'ailleurs à supprimer
quelques vieilles maisons on achète et
qu'on démolit la salle qu'est tombante
on veut l'abattre
toute la salle du fond hélas hélas la
place sera refaite
il y aura une partie plus haute la
partie noire il a plusieurs fers au feu
mais si depuis des mois on parle de lui
bien au delà de ces communes c'est pour
cette nouveauté
voilà là c'est raté les métiers la
télémédecine qui ne fait que démarrer
on en était ce jour-là à la 100ème
consultation à distance avec un médecin
dont le cabinet est à granville 1 80 km
[Musique]
de scop et puis on va écouter votre
coeur s'il vous plaît ça paraît très
technique mais le patient semble
rassurer ah oui sûrement fait effet nude
[Musique]
saint georges de rouelley n'avait plus
de médecins en lien avec tout ce que la
normandie compte d'autorités médicale on
a choisi d'expérimenter une formule qui
laisse le voisinage dubitatif
à commencer par baron thon ou le maire
était du métier
le mal des campagnes pas de problème
médical il n'est pas seulement dans les
campagnes quand vous allez à paris le
nombre de médecins généralistes diminue
quand vous allez dans les banlieues
c'est catastrophique
la solution comme souvent ici est venu
de l'étranger elle s'appelle maria
garcia castillo elle ne chôme pas dans
son cabinet alors comment ça va c'est
aussi l'accent espagnol qui résonnera
bientôt dans l'impeccable pôle de santé
du teilleul l'heure de la retraite a
sonné pour les deux généralistes
historique
ils attendent avec impatience leur
remplaçante en chair et en os
avez-vous loi de la télémédecine trouve
un peu paradoxal que le thé les médecins
ne soit pas capable de prendre sa
voiture pour venir consulter ici 48
heures aux trois jours par semaine
ça me paraît tout simple beaucoup plus
simple que faire une consultation à 50
ou 100 km avec un infirmier
intermédiaire le maire et promoteur de
la sphère n'y voit pas la panacée mais à
romed parmi d'autres ça peut tout à fait
se conjuguer et je crois d'ailleurs
prenez l'exemple d'une mère de famille
aujourd'hui qui veut travailler à temps
partiel les chez elle
docteur et peut faire de 30,0 thématique
au 2e mais l'idéal pour revitaliser le
pays n'est-il pas d'y vivre dit rester
ou d'y revenir ce jeune enseignant en
histoire géographie a fait ce choix là
il travaille sur le vieux passé les
années glorieuses de saint georges de
rouelley sans désespérer de l'avenir
je trouve qu'il ya quand même encore une
image de la réalité qui est très
mauvaise qui était mal perçue encore la
réalité
pas besoin d'aller en ville pour avoir
accès à la culture et au sport on itunes
nicole en atout il ya plein d'avantagés
à vivre en campagne
petit à petit il va la voir un phénomène
inverse c'est à dire que les gens vont
venir
de plus en plus à la campagne et ce
jour-là au bar du coin
celui qui donne le ton on était même
d'humeur badine il n'y a pas de magie on
va pas repeupler les campagnes comme
c'était au 19e siècle ça va pas non plus
mais malgré tout il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où s'asseoir coq qui relève
le défi
on veut qu'ils aient qui garde la tête
hors de l'eau moi je suis content de
voir ça